yeah you know when to welcome to this
video which covers the game between not
going to pronounce that correctly here
trying and petrified no not getting any
lower for that problem so let's forget
the game hokum ballad that i should
mention that the times not are not
corrected it automatically gives the 15
15 year the software so when by the way
i try to do it only chest just to
mention it but it doesn't have this time
stems either so i didn't see a big point
of completely redoing my layout on the
time steps would have been nice but i
didn't get them only chest so let's get
going we have a king's indian in this
game and the white player opt for a
classical variation and place d5 the
Petrosian system and this line is not
much in fashion nowadays in fact never
has been in big fashion there was a
period of time in the early 1990s when
running the chrome neck plated
successfully to be Kasparov for example
either in a pretty nice game nowadays
it's not seen all that often even though
I don't particularly understand why this
is the case I don't think it has less of
a bite and many other lines that white
plays regularly one point of the
Petrosian is that like showing that
white has not yet cancelled while having
cleared in central situations and some
lines can really be relevant why this
delay in castling this is especially
true if black plays one of the VLS
popsugar ninth for example let's say
something like night eh five or so and
something like g3 makes lots of sense
you can compare this variation on
tons with the h3 line something like
that for example is well known in 2h
three lines where g3 is a move and you
can really argue that h3 is not
particularly useful here you would
rather have the bishop on e2 so there
are some parallels as usual in those
closed openings and okay black went a 5
which is them tried and tested main line
6 showing some space on the queenside
and stopping or stalling whites advance
like this Bishop b5 played the white
hard the main move and black goes h6 I
think it's a good idea to get this move
in right away if you don't do that and
play em yeah let's say here and start
with this move I think then white gains
an additional option by playing an early
92 the thing is an important to
understand that in the classical King
Finian the ideal setup for wide is
something like this he would not go to
h4 but back to you three probably where
we get this optimal setup knives here
bishops here why is this the best
possible said ìwhy discover in the
center very reliably with those nights
and the attack on the queenside would be
extremely effective because the bishop
is involved here in the main line
classical oftentimes white combines
night mf3 to e 1 2 d 3 and then we
should be three this is just quicker and
the night only two is more aggressive
than the light on these 3s the night
here have c4 after later c-45 so black
is right in flying h6 immediately that
gets this option out of the way now now
I have a wide surprisingly place we
should be three back and that in my mind
doesn't make any
sense you should just go to h4 and play
the main line this has been played a lot
over the years like is usually starting
with 9 a-6 after which white castles or
place 92 note that here the bishop is on
h4 not only three that's not supporting
any creature claim yeah this is the
start of the main line which usually
continues with moves like Queen 38
capsules 9h seven things like that the
devil move order and Mesa sometimes
white went to e3 I of them and I don't
think that this is all that great Black
now has to play the move that she plays
but he did play it Bishop sorry Nigel
for you need to disturb white
immediately him before he sets up the 92
scheme that would be pretty bad so 9g
for disturbing white white went to
detune you can also ask if he wanted all
that why not this immediately absolutely
right now if you wanted to put the
bishop here you should have done so
immediately now if he an ID for you at
least have the additional option of
going Bishop to g5 which is a legitimate
line it's okay for black but definitely
in comparison i think it makes more
sense than this yeah i went back to d2
and black played f5 with standard porn
break that like is awesome going for a 3
back to f6 so i think while white hasn't
done all that much in the last couple of
moves black cottage main playing I would
have five yeah white now is captured and
if I this is probably the best choice it
was impossible to keep the center now
anymore something like that is not
helping all that much so take stakes
Quincy one a little bit critical of that
as well I really don't think that
provoking King edge
helps a lot but it's probably highly
developed that terrible just doesn't
lead to all that much so King age seven
instead of this and f4 was also an
option bit of an unusual confirmation
but it makes some sense because here the
e4 square which is usually the problem
with pushing the porn up therefore is
definitely not in white large hands
black have things like that of Bishop f5
and should be very ok diem he played
King age seven I think after kh7 white
and probably should have done something
a lot more energetic than what he did he
played Queen to see to after yoga in
mind what I don't see the next movie and
I don't quite know the games / hot he
had interesting ideas in the situation
something like the super suit for
example the pretty brutal move g4 was
interesting yeah what is the point if
black takes this weary caption and this
in fact is pretty nice look at this 90s
there's 95 and this is absolutely
terrible from like there's some things
like that you're not going to survive so
g4 was an interesting option like has to
react differently probably form is what
you have to do and then the position is
extremely complicated and really tough
to assess this was the thing why should
I pledge if form and really make a mess
out of it now this is pointing towards
f4 probably being the better choice if a
black white or ever played Quincy tool
and this doesn't really do all that much
it prepares long capsules but the king
is unsafe on the queenside as we will
see 986 now lon capsules and night
before and 489
and that before merely it was possible
if I was also a good move and now 90 td5
was an interesting trick and night
before also was possible here right away
the idea being that after clean to be
one let him take on define the night on
edge forth always a little bit stranded
that move was played in the game it's
the same idea of horse takes and print a
page for ya what is the main point of
this position I think that one issue
providers that his king is potentially
quite unsaved this is pretty much
underlined after this the next move that
black now found is very strong he played
92 before and after that why does not
really get any any decent chance that
any more to get back in the game he
probably should have taken on a farm in
this position now this is the better
choice it opens up the a file but it
does not yet lead into yeah any specific
problem for example it black young just
continues to develop you go like it
would be one I can be one I think this
is probably an equal ish this is also
why this was probably a bit better and
directly take 95 so this is what
happened and after Queen d8 bishops III
will spray and now blacks very good move
was night before there is strong yeah
directly challenging the white pieces
and the thing is why definitely does not
want to give up this bishop and getting
into into a situation where the
this Bishop here doesn't have any kind
of opponent let's aim but you also don't
like to do what in the game was played
to give up the 995 and open up the
eighth on so takes yeah and now wise
choices are ya all pretty awful it took
him taking on B form doesn't help either
yeah something like that yeah yeah this
is pretty awful currently black is some
even a porn up in addition to its really
excellent position so it was traded on
g7 and now g4 yeah desperately trying to
make something happen but it doesn't
really do much at the end and a tube
while saying so probably why had to do
this it's not much fun blacks moves I
easy something like this should be sick
screen f6 yeah but it's probably better
than this group takes a to it this is
just too important a pawn to give up so
G take that five which it takes check
not I'm luckiest winning there is not
much hope for white main threat now is
III you okay yeah I'm not keeping all
the materials and the thing is the White
King will never find a safe place
anymore you can even get white would
have liked you could teleport the King
to any given square there is no safe
square even h2 which is relatively best
doesn't feel particularly safe so check
check now if white takes on b7 what's
happening Queen chapel
neck we define is good enough something
like that it's going to be a pretty easy
win and the game wyd give up that room
and 205 which can ultimately failed to
queen bee one check after which wide
resigned so King be too III what's the
cuter point at the end so um let's have
a rattle of the skin soompi moments I
think White's opening player is fairly
harmed us with Bishop to e3 and Link one
black did was fine you probably should
go at four in this position to avoid
this g4 option which looked a little bit
done that look dangerous really and here
the play will become also quite sharp
for example something like that is
possible any idea what's going on I have
no idea yeah it's pretty sharp so here
g4 was really interesting the other
interesting move was g3 or g4 is the
move that probably fits best with what
why did perform of course black does not
have to check on g4 this was just one
line 96 is possible or again at four
after Queen c2 I think yeah a night
before was an improvement after which
blackish is better and after white
missed opportunity here to take on 85 it
was really necessary not so much because
pawn could be taken but to take control
over the be four square after white half
yeah not taking this opportunity I think
the game really turned into black favor
quite clearly it was also relatively
easy for like to play ok I hope you
enjoyed the coverage of this typically
fighting Kings Indian game thanks for
watching
you